[Musique]
nous sommes le 15 août 1969 il est midi
au plus fort de l'été à ajaccio en corse
des cris jaillissent de la grande maison
de la famille bonaparte et laetitia
assistés de son mari carlo donne
naissance sur le tapis du salon à son
deuxième fils napoleone mon appart
ajaccio c'est dans cette bourgade
tranquille posé au fond d'une des plus
belles baies de méditerranée que grandit
le petit napoleone le futur empereur des
français napoléon 1er
faut savoir quel jacques souhaite une
très petite ville à 3000 habitants au
xviiie siècle c'est presque un village
ou à peine plus un bourg
c'est une petite ville qui vit
énormément de la pêche de la pêche au
corail qui ressemblait à un petit à
naples
[Musique]
napoleone grandi dans une famille très
respecté ici ajaccio carlo bonaparte et
son père est issu de la petite noblesse
de la région de gênes en italie
les bonaparte et sont présents encore
depuis maintenant trois siècles se sont
appelés les pieds noirs de la corse de
l'époque donc des familles génoise les
bonaparte et occupe des fonctions assez
importante dans la ville il ya toujours
un bonaparte membres du conseil
municipal du aux xviie et au xviiie
siècle les boues en aparté c'est ce
qu'on appelle un clan en corse une
famille puissante qui possèdent des
terres et qui se paye les services et
l'allégeance de paysans de la région et
c'est une famille qui est donc un réseau
social très fort des biens fonciers à
las des domaines où elle cultive l'olive
la vigne puis également des fruits à la
des troupeaux ça fait aussi une grosse
clientèle dans le sens commun du terme
c'est à dire beaucoup de gens qui
travaillent pour elles et qui sont
pratiquement une petite armée en cas de
nécessité
[Musique]
la mère de napoléon n'est la belle
laetitia règne sur la maison bonaparte
est rempli de grand-mère de tentes de
nourrice qui l'assistent dans
l'éducation de ses nombreux enfants
letizia ramolino aura douze enfants 12
enfants c'est une magnifique figures de
femmes dans l'histoire de france
laetitia magistral femmes qui se
trouvant à la tête de cette cette
fratrie va devoir et ben a assuré le
quotidien
douze enfants dont huit survivront après
la naissance
cinq garçons et trois filles on imagine
cette maison à la fois dans les petites
ruelles d'ajaccio mais mais sous ce
soleil de plomb avec cette plate et
d'enfants avaient de joyeux en même
temps il était assez livrés à eux-mêmes
de toute la bande des enfants du
quartier
napoleone est sans conteste le plus
turbulent tout le monde le surnomme
riboud l'yonne le perturbateur
ça devait être un enfant extrêmement
turbulent extrêmement volontaire je ne
sais pas s'il était capricieux mais en
tout cas il voulait il voulait imposer
sa vision des choses à toute la famille
il aurait battu terroriser son frère
depuis leur plus tendre enfance et
jeunesse qui était pourtant son aîné ont
vécu un peu sous la coupe de napoléon
dominateurs avec toute sa famille
napoleone s'identifie très tôt à des
figures masculines et viril
tous les soirs au son du tambour il
court en direction de la citadelle
d'ajaccio qui se trouve à quelques
encablures de la maison familiale
ici le petit garçon de 6 ans assiste
fasciné à son spectacle préféré la
relève de la garde
napoléon petit voit les militaires
défilé dans la dans la citadelle et les
fasciné par ces beaux uniformes par
parcelle ces uniformes rutilants par par
le tambour qui l'émeut qui l'amour il
sera ému toute sa vie par le bruit du
temps pour semer au milieu il alors
défiler avec eux il a voulu goûter le
pain des soldats il a trouvé ça très bon
et est donc on voit qu'il conte dire que
ça ça m'intéresse tout tout petit
napoleone bref de devenir l'un de ses
beaux soldats
ils les dessine en ordre de bataille sur
les murs de sa chambre il se met aussi à
manger leur pain du pain dur pour mieux
s'accoutumer à son futur métier et ils
s'identifient très très tôt alors à ce
qu'il a sous les yeux c'est à dire aux
militaires français qui occupe la corse
ces soldats français que napoleone à
venir tant sont les nouveaux maîtres de
la corse une armée d'occupation
âgé de 7 ans napoleone ne sait pas que
l'arrivée de ces soldats l'année de sa
naissance a profondément bouleversé
l'histoire de sa famille
et
tout s'est joué c'est un an auparavant
en 1769 l'année de la naissance de
napoleone
le royaume de france achète la corse à
la petite république de gênes incapable
de contrôler cette île rebelle
inacceptable pour le grand patriote
pascal paoli qui appelle les corses à
résister au nouvel envahisseur
bien décidé à prendre l'île par les
armes les soldats français affrontent
les troupes de pascal paoli à la
bataille de ponte novu le 8 mai 1769
trois mois avant la naissance de
napoléonienne
[Musique]
carlo bonaparte et est l'un de ces
patriotes corses qui se bat contre les
français aponte nouveau un vaillant
guerrier il est même le lieutenant de
pascal paoli
mais les troupes indépendantistes sont
écrasés et les français prennent
officiellement possession de la corse au
nom du roi de france louis 15
[Musique]
pascal paoli s'exile en angleterre pour
continuer la lutte mais carlo bonaparte
et lui prend une décision surprenante il
décide de rester en corse et de se
rallier aux français il a compris qu'en
collaborant avec le nouvel occupant
ils pouvaient obtenir beaucoup davantage
pour son clan
car l'eau devient charles
[Musique]
charles est un homme qui à cheville et
au corps l'ambition pour sa maison comme
on disait pour son clan pour sa famille
la réussite de sa famille passe avant
tout et la réussite veut dire la fortune
et le pouvoir
en 1776 napoléon à 7 ans au vu de ces
prédispositions évidente pour le métier
des armes
charles décide de lui bâtir une carrière
de soldat dans l'armée française charles
bonaparte se dit donc maintenant je vais
profiter de mes compétences et je vais
les négocier avec les français donc la
négociation avec charles c'est quoi
c'est si vous venez de notre côté que
vous acceptez de mettre vos compétences
au service de la gouvernance française
de la corse
en échange nous intégrons de notre
système
[Musique]
charles bonaparte et est un fin
négociateur en échange de l'allégeance
de son clan royaume de france
il obtient la reconnaissance officielle
de son titre de noblesse
le sésame indispensable qui va lui
permettre d'assurer l'ascension de ses
enfants au sein de la monarchie
française
et le 10 mai 1779 c'est charles deux
bouts en aparté représentants de la
noblesse de corse qui se rend à
versailles pour présenter au roi louis
saez en personne l'hommage de l'île de
corse
une consécration pour le petit
n'oublions qui obtient à la suite de
cette visite une bourse royal d'études
pour ses deux fils aîné joseph et
napoléon
[Musique]
grâce à l'obstination de son père
napoléon à 9 ans seulement qu'il sa
famille son île natale et part vers la
france ce grand royaume qui va faire de
lui pense t'il un grand soldat mais
livré à lui même est soumis à la
discipline de fer des écoles militaires
françaises
le jeune napoléon va vivre un terrible
déracinement
[Musique]
non
napoléon prend la direction de la
champagne dans le nord-est de la france
[Musique]
ici plus rien ne ressemble à sa corse
déjà à l'est d'ajaccio à brienne en
champagne s'échanger plus que deux
mondes
c'est presque changé de planète à
l'époque rien ne peut lui avoir donné
l'idée ni du paysage de champagne ni du
climat donc le premier sentiment c'est
le dépaysement total
on l'a h à sa famille ont la rage à ça
mais ces jeunes ne vont vraiment c'est
un tout petit garçon de toute façon
qu'on soit bonaparte ou pas c'est
douloureux c'est un arrachement le 15
mai 1779 napoléon intègre l'école
militaire de brienne près de 3
le petit boursiers corse va côtoyer ici
pendant cinq ans des fils de la noblesse
française qui se destinent au métier des
armes
à brienne il découvre un monde nouveau
dans lequel il va devoir se faire une
place il ya un problème de classe
sociale qui leur sang sans doute pour la
première fois c'est à dire certains
jeunes élèves officiers à partir de très
grandes familles françaises donc arrive
avec la morgue qui va avec leur statut
social il va trouver confronté à une
noblesse française réelles des gens qui
ont des titres noblesse qui remonte qui
remonte au moyen-âge et qui se moque de
ceux napo napoleone bonaparte et qui
parle un français tout à fait incorrect
et donc évidemment ce jeune homme qui a
d'abord un prénom personne n'a jamais
entendu napoleone qui parle pas très
bien le français encore à ce moment là
bien évidemment il va être l'objet de
moqueries alors la peau leone et devient
la bâillonner on opte son accent bref on
lui fait comprendre qu'il ne sera jamais
un noble de vieille souche il restera un
étranger un corps sono imprononçable
napoléon fils d'une très grande famille
corse qu'on prend subitement qu'en
france il n'est plus rien ça fait partie
des des événements qui forge un
caractère c'est ce sentiment
d'humiliation ce sentiment d'isolement
le sentiment on va se construire compte
et pour montrer quelque chose et je vais
leur montrer et je serai celui qui sera
à la fois le le le plus travailleur
j'aurai les notes
pour ne pas céder à la mélancolie le
jeune des racines et se jette à corps
perdu dans le travail
certes il médiocre en français et en
langues étrangères les il est très doué
pour la géographie et les mathématiques
[Musique]
son esprit rapide lui permet de résoudre
les problèmes de géométrie les plus
complexes
en revanche le jeune napoléon est un
grand solitaire
ne participa aux bagarres collective aux
blagues de potache qui font le quotidien
de la vie du collège etc en effet une
fois sortis de la classe il se rendait à
la bibliothèque qui était fort bien des
challandais
alors il lit comme il lira toute sa vie
de tous dans le désordre le plus complet
littérature géographie histoire
orientale histoire antique
c'est dans ses lectures que napoléon va
trouver les modèles auxquels il va
s'identifier toute sa vie il est comme
tous les gens de sa génération il est
fasciné et dominé par les grands anciens
alexandre le grand jules césar
les récits des exploits militaires de
ces grands anciens vont être une
révélation
non
tous ont en commun d'être épris de
l'amour de la gloire et pas de la gloire
n'a pas de la célébrité de la gloire au
sens qu'on lui donnait au xviiie siècle
c'est-à-dire conquérir la gloire c'est
vivre dans la tête des gens à tout
jamais et sur la surface de la terre
c'est mettre son nom plus haut que tout
inscrire son nom dans l'histoire et il
est possédé par cette passion et à
partir de cela et s'imagine à notre
avenir un avenir de guerre un avenir de
conquête un avenir de chef d'état déjà
alors qu'il est tout jeune
comme les grands anciens napoléon rêve
lui aussi de connaître la gloire et il
va y goûter un jour de l'hiver 1783
ce matin là les élèves découvrent la
cour de l'école recouverte de neige
les élèves naturellement s'organise en
deux camps et s'attaquent les uns les
autres
napoléon à 14 ans il prend d'autorité la
tête de l'un des deux camps conçoit des
stratégies d'attac lance des manoeuvres
ambitieux sous les encouragements des
professeurs et des habitants du quartier
[Musique]
hélas le chef s'est révélée d'où la
reconnaissance de ses petits camarades
et ça pour lui c'est important c'était
la première fois qu'il avait la
reconnaissance ses petits camarades
et ça ça va lui rester ça va le marquer
donc il va comprendre qu'à travers ses
prouesses stratégique
il peut être le chef et le premier une
autorité naturelle du sang froid
napoléon découvre qu'il a toutes les
qualités pour commander alors au mois
d'août 1784 à 15 ans napoléon kit
brienne et intègre la prestigieuse école
militaire de paris où il rejoint l'élite
de l'armée du roi
les officiers
d'abord pour la première fois il est à
paris et découvre ce qui est alors une
ville extraordinaire et une ville dont
il ne pouvait avoir l'idée qu'ils
comptent probablement un million
d'habitants une très grande ville mais
quelques mois seulement après son
arrivée à paris
napoléon apprend la mort subite de son
père charles
[Musique]
malgré ses 15 ans napoléon endosse le
rôle de nouveau chef du clan bonaparte
pour subvenir aux besoins de sa famille
il lui faut passer le concours de
l'école au plus vite devenir officier et
toucher ainsi sa première soldes
[Musique]
oa
et à l'école militaire qui est une
grande institution pour la france royal
de cette époque il va essayer de faire
en très peu de temps
ce que d'autres faisaient en trois ans
napoléon réussi son pari au bout de sept
mois de travail acharné à 16 ans
seulement il passe avec succès le
concours de l'école militaire un exploit
qui impressionne l'un de ses professeurs
corse deux nations et de caractère
ce jeune homme ira loin si les
circonstances le favorise clairement il
ne sort pas très bien il est dans les
quarantièmes ça ça n'est pas brillant
enfin quand on l'a fait en trois fois
moins de temps que les camarades
oui ça alors là ça signifie quelque
chose donc c'est un élève qui finit un
élève officier qui finit sa période de
formation de manière plutôt brillante et
qui va partir
occupé son premier poste à valence
napoléon est fier il porte maintenant
l'uniforme de lieutenant de l'armée du
roi louis saez
[Musique]
mais il va vite déchanter car la
monarchie française ne pourra pas lui
permettre de satisfaire ses rêves de
gloire
[Musique]
dans son régiment à valence napoléon est
terriblement déçu par la routine de la
ville garnison
ces corvées et ses interminables tour de
garde
mais surtout il se rend compte qu'il n'a
aucune perspective de carrière
[Musique]
ne pas mourir
il ya eu des mesures prises par le
gouvernement et qui limitent l'accès au
grade aux nobles qui peuvent prouver une
certaine ancienneté de noblesse qui
n'est pas son cas parce qu'il est issu
de la petite noblesse napoléon ne pourra
jamais dépasser le rang de
sous-officiers
très insuffisant pour satisfaire son
immense ambition
il est absolument convaincu que pour lui
il n'ya pas de destins possibles en
france et ils pressent un peu les
capacités qui sont en lui
donc ils cherchent désespérément un
endroit ouvriers et un endroit où vivre
quelque chose et avoir un destin
il faut ajouter à ça mais les idées
qu'ils se mettent à circuler à ce moment
là on essaie le siècle des lumières des
idées d'égalité des idées de rejet des
privilèges et donc évidemment quand on
met l'ensemble ça donne dans la tête de
napoléon un mélange un petit peu
d'étonnant
napoléon à 17 ans
il est coupé de la corse et de sa
famille depuis l'âge de 9 ans et il est
immanquablement gagné par le mal du pays
cette france n'est pas faite pour lui il
en est convaincu
c'est en corse sur sa terre natale qu'il
doit écrire son destin
pour bonaparte ça n'a probablement pas
été facile d'assumer les choix qui avait
été fait par son père parce que lui ce
rêve comme le plus corse et des corses
le héros de jeunesse de de bonaparte
c'est paoli napoléon ce rêve au nouveau
libérateur de la corse
que deviendrons nous nous ôtera fortunés
corse
continuerons-nous a baisé la main
insolente qui nous opprime
se prend à rêver de devenir le nouveau
paoli et d'arracher l'île de corse à la
domination française
c'est à dire à la domination du roi
auquel d'un autre côté et simultanément
il a prêté serment la corse où la france
napoléon va devoir choisir
très vite le 14 juillet 1789 la foule
parisienne attaque la prison d'ain
restigné
c'est le début de la révolution
française un tremblement de terre un
chaos politique qui va secouer la france
pendant dix ans et dont le jeune
napoléon bonaparte pas très habilement
se servir pour se fabriquer un destin
mais ce jour là le jeune bonaparte 19
ans est loin des événements il est dans
sa garnison près de valence est ne joue
aucun rôle
en 1789 lorsqu'éclate la révolution
française napoléon n'a qu'une idée
qu'une obsession la corse
donc il passe totalement à côté de cet
événement qui va lui offrir un dessin
napoléon apprend que la déclaration des
droits de l'homme et du citoyen
promulguée par les révolutionnaires
aboli les privilèges de la noblesse et
instituts l'égalité en droits de tous
les citoyens
le décret qui freinait sa carrière
militaire n'existe donc plus napoléon
peut donc prétendre au plus haut grade
dans l'armée
mais son rêve corse est plus fort que
tout
il est temps pour lui de libérer son
pays la corse un projet fou dont ils ne
mesurent pas les conséquences
au mois de septembre 1789 à 20 ans
napoléon retrouve sacoor son
effervescence
profitant des troubles révolutionnaires
le chef indépendantiste pascal paoli a
fait son grand retour pour reprendre le
pouvoir sur l'île napoléon ébloui
rencontre pour la première fois son
héros de jeunesse
il lui propose naïvement de devenir son
bras droit comme l'avait été charles son
père avant qu'il ne se rallie aux
français aux yeux de paoli qui
pratiquent cette sorte de vertus corse
qui est de ne jamais oublier les
affronts les fils de charles bonaparte
seront comme paoli les appelait les fils
de charles
il porte la faute du père et il la porte
à tout jamais si bien que quels que
soient les efforts faits par napoléon et
par joseph et bien poli ne les acceptera
jamais
l'impardonnable faute de charles
condamne tout le clan bonaparte à fuir
la corse pour échapper à la vengeance de
paoli
[Musique]
ainsi prend fin trois siècles d'histoire
corse pour la famille bonaparte
cet arrachement à la terre natale et
d'une brutalité inouïe pour napoléon
ce qui arrive à napoléon ce moment là
bien c'est quelque chose de très grave
c'est que logiquement il va devoir tirer
un trait sur cette identité corse très
profonde sur cet attachement à la corse
je dirais charnelle est aussi politique
sentimentale il va en quelque sorte
c'est comme s'ils se couper un bras
c'est comme si il sait comme si
déchirait une partie de lui-même c'est
comme si quelque chose d'affectif on lui
avait été sacrifié
à ce moment là napoléon se rêver en
grand libérateur de la corse
mais c'est idéal politique est à jamais
perdu son rêve brisé il devient un être
mélancolique et désabusé
[Musique]
désormais c'est avec le regard détaché
d'un étranger qui va observer les
patients politique qui secoue la france
à partir de maintenant il va s'engager
uniquement là où il ya des opportunités
pour faire avancer sa carrière
[Musique]
napoléon à 23 ans en 1793 il retrouve
une france en plein chaos
maximilien robespierre est au pouvoir il
a lancé une politique de terreur
révolutionnaire contre tous ses ennemis
politiques
la république a été proclamée et pour
empêcher tout retour à la monarchie
le roi louis saez a été décapité en
place publique
l'europe a peur voilà comment les
caricaturistes anglais montrent les
révolutionnaires français
[Musique]
pour faire tomber la jeune république
coupe la tête des rois les monarques
d'europe vont lui imposer une guerre qui
va durer vingt ans
[Musique]
il faut sauver la patrie pour se
défendre la république française va
faire appel à une nouvelle génération de
jeunes officiers talentueux pour
commander ses armées
la guerre est un accélérateur de
d'histoire et napoléon bonaparte profite
aussi de ce moment exceptionnel qui met
en scène toute une nouvelle génération
il est bien placé et il est l'homme
qu'il faut au moment où il faut napoléon
réengager afin de quatre ans avec une
belle promotion à la clé capitaine
d'artillerie
il est envoyé pour défendre la ville de
toul aux assiégés par la flotte
britannique la napoléon va montrer un
véritable don pour la guerre un don qui
va fasciner son entourage a toujours il
découvre réellement la guerre et il y
montre d'emblée une attitude quasiment
sans limite comme ce comme s'il était né
pour ça alors qu'il ne l'a jamais connue
comme s'il n'avait pas besoin de période
d'apprentissage ou d'expérimentation et
il est prêt à tout pour conserver ses
idées de gloire parce que nous sommes
très très orgueilleux et il est prêt à
mourir près affronter la mort
véritablement au milieu de la bataille
napoléon déployé une énergie sidérante
il semble indifférent aux dangers qui
l'entourent
il a un courage physique absolue c'est à
dire la mort ne lui fait pas peur du
coup la mort des autres ne
l'impressionnent pas non plus
napoléon est également un tacticien hors
pair grâce à une utilisation millimétré
de ces canaux il parvient à repousser la
flotte anglaise qui assiège et toulon
une prouesse qui lui vaut de passer au
grade de général de brigade à toulon
napoléon a impressionné un certain paul
barras c'est un homme politique de tout
premier plan un ennemi juré de
robespierre qui attend son heure pour
prendre les rênes de la révolution par
assa à deviner les capacités
extraordinaires qui sont celles de ce
jeune général et puis chez barras comme
toujours il ya quelque chose de tout à
fait intéressé il se dit qu'après tout
ce général un jour pourra lui être utile
en mettant son talent militaire au
service de paul barras napoléon
bonaparte va propulser sa carrière vers
les sommets
[Applaudissements]
paris le 28 juillet 1794
six mois après la victoire de toulon
cette fois c'est robespierre qui est
guillotiné barras veut s'emparer du
pouvoir
mais il a besoin d'un bras armé pour
contrer un complot royalistes qui veut
lui barrer la route et réinstaller la
monarchie en france les royalistes
envisage de remettre sur le trône le
comte de provence futur louis xviii
donc il ya là vraiment un danger il se
souvient de ce jeune général bonaparte
qui l'attend impressionné à toulon alors
un soir tandis que napoléon est en train
d'assister à un spectacle à la
comédie-française barras ma le chercher
et lui fait une proposition pour le
moins surprenante l'aider à sauver la
république contre les royalistes
napoléon à 26 ans comme un parieur il
s'interroge quel parti prendre à la
tille prendre le parti de la convention
où le parti des royalistes
de quel côté était la fortune
le 5 octobre 1795 il est 9h du matin
napoléon a choisi de défendre la
république
et il ne reculera pas avec 5000 hommes
et 40 canaux ils repoussent 25 mille
insurgés royalistes qui menacent
l'assemblée de la république
bilan trois cents morts et lorsque au
petit matin il rentre chez lui il écrit
immédiatement un billet à son frère
joseph où il lui écrit cette phrase qui
est une phrase de joueurs qui a tenté la
fortune les déroulée sur le tapis vert
et la fortune et de mon côté
un choix plein d'opportunisme
napoléon a peut-être sauvé la république
mais il a surtout sauvé la carrière de
paul barras pour le remercier marasme
affaires de napoléon l'un des
personnages les plus importants de son
nouveau pouvoir
[Musique]
à 26 ans napoléon est maintenant un
homme qui compte
ils logent à paris dans un bel hôtel
particulier de la place vendôme
c'est l'un des protégés du nouvel homme
fort de la république paul mara ce avec
son nouveau look de roi en plus mais il
est à la tête du directoire
un régime corrompu soutenu par une
bourgeoisie qui s'est enrichie pendant
la révolution le général bonaparte et
leur bras armé
[Musique]
c'est donc le plus important général à
l'intérieur du territoire il commande
paris et sa région
c'est là que ça se passe un poste très
important mais sa tâche est ingrate
il est chargée de mater les révoltes de
la faim qui éclatent dans les quartiers
populaires de la capitale
il y à une partie de la population qui
meurent de faim et des gens qui se
suicident chaque nuit en sautant dans la
seine et à côté de cela un luxe inouï
pour les profiteurs de la révolution le
roy barras comme on l'appelle maintenant
introduit son protégé dans les salons de
la haute société du directoire qui prend
du bon temps
[Musique]
ils ont vraiment des défaites
complètement incroyable que barras donné
à la fois au luxembourg et aussi dans
ses propriétés à suresnes près de paris
où il y avait un château où il recevait
beaucoup d'effets est complètement folle
un exutoire pour les bourgeois bien
heureux d'avoir survécu à la terreur
révolutionnaire ya une forme de
catharsis de défoulement après après la
terreur tout le monde a eu peur on a eu
peur dont vivent la vie il ya cette soif
de plaisir soif de volupté la mode est
magnifique pour les femmes ce sont des
robes en tulle de soie ou ou en
mousseline extrêmement transparents on
n'est même pas de brassières dont les
femmes ont les seins qui pointent pour
pour les pour les hommes aussi c'est
l'appel au hawk ride
les femmes sont ici les plus belles du
monde elles sont la grande occupation
est la grande affaire
l'incertitude de l'avenir porte à ne
rien épargné aux plaisirs du présent si
napoléon ne perdre aucune miette du
spectacle
ici dans la haute société du territoire
personne ne prête attention à ce jeune
militaire timide et emprunter
[Musique]
napoléon mesure 1 mètre 69 une taille
normale pour un homme de cette époque
mais son physique frêle et sa pâleur
juvénile ne peuvent pas laisser deviner
les hautes fonctions qu'il occupe le
jeune bonaparte et un peu l'invité le
cousin de province qu'on tolère dans ce
salon très luxueux parce que lui même
n'a pas l'apparence luxueuse ni très
chic il est mal attifée il est pas très
bien soigné un peu maladif avec ses
cheveux raides un petit peu gras son
petit catogan maigrelet enfin il n'est
pas très très séduisant
le roy barras l'introduit maintenant
auprès de l'une des reines des salons
parisiens
joséphine de beauharnais une élégante
veuve ode aux accents créoles et au
charme langoureux c'est vraiment
quelqu'un qui est clair à salon quand
elle est là en plus c'est tout à fait
bien élevé elle sait tenir une
conversation faire les correspondances
c'est quelqu'un du meilleur monde c'est
une femme pour être charme une très
belle femme avec un ton un petit peu
traînons c'est cet axe ont des îles
quelque chose d'un dolan de voluptueux
c'est une des maîtresses de barras et
d'autres encore
mais ça napoléon ne le sait pas et idées
tout de suite captivé par cette femme du
monde aux manières si raffiné c'est un
coup de foudre de son côté parce que
pour lui joséphine
c'est une grande dame c'est de plus une
grande dame de l'ancien régime ivoire
joséphine cet aristocrate de l'ancien
régime qui le fascine parce que si
joséphine n'a pas fréquenté la cour elle
a quand même été lié de très près à tout
ce monde aristocratique qui est une
espèce de fantasme pour m'épauler en ce
sens grandit quand il est auprès d'elle
là ils se disent ah ça c'est une femme
du monde et puis va lui rendre visite et
lui rend visite rue chanteraine dans un
petit hôtel particulier
ça n'est pas luxueux ça n'est pas
l'esbroufé mais tout de même c'est un
joli petit hôtel particulier epona
parfois ça se dit ouh là là là j'ai
affaire à une grande table
entre les mains expertes de joséphine à
26 ans napoléon va découvrir l'amour
physique dont il ignore à peu près tout
elle lui fait découvrir des choses dont
ils n'avaient pas idée où elle va lui
faire connaître le plaisir réellement 7
heures du matin je me réveille plein de
toit d'où ses incomparables joséphine
quel effet faites vous sur mon coeur me
au dolce amor reçoit un millier de
baiser mais ne m'en donne pas car ils
brûlent encens la façon dont il va
tomber amoureux de joséphine nous fait
penser un peu à ce que nos psychologues
moderne appellerait de la dépendance
c'est-à-dire qu'il a véritablement il
est drogué à sa joséphine en quelque
sorte envahi par une passion dévorante
napoléon au bout de quelques semaines
demandent la belle aristocrate en
mariage
[Musique]
pour joséphine il n'en est pas question
ce jeune général est juste un amant
parmi d'autres mais pour paul barras ce
projet de mariage l'occasion toute
trouvée pour se débarrasser d'une
maîtresse devenues encombrantes
et c'est pourquoi il va intriguer et
faire pression pour qu'elle se résigne à
ce mariage en lui disant que le moment
est venu de faire une feinte et quant à
faire une feinte autant faire une fin
grandiose et que certes bonaparte c'est
pas grand chose mais que bonaparte ça va
devenir quelque chose
très vite le 9 mars 1796 napoléon épouse
joséphine ans
la cérémonie de mariage est vite expédié
la belle aristocrate est à peine
conquise que napoléon part au galop vers
une autre conquête vers ce qu'il désire
par dessus tout la gloire
[Musique]
à 26 ans grâce à l'intervention de paul
barras napoléon a décroché la mission
qu'il espérait tant le commandement
d'une armée soixante mille hommes sous
ses ordres
sa mission repousser des armées
autrichiennes et piémontaise qui
menacent d'envahir la france à la
frontière italienne mais napoléon
découvre que l'armée qu'on lui a confiée
est dans un piteux état
ces sommes sont mal équipées et mal
nourris a priori impossible avec une
telle armée de réaliser son rêve de
gloire mais la motivation du jeune
officier est plus forte que tout et il
est bien décidé à réaliser un coup
d'éclat alors il commence par re motiver
ces pauvres soldats en devenir soldat
vous êtes nu mal nourris le gouvernement
vous dois beaucoup
je veux vous emmener dans les plus
fertiles plein du monde
vous y trouverez honneur gloire et
richesse ses harangues formidable vous
allez enfin parvenir à remporter des
victoires
et lorsque vous rentrerez en france vous
pourrez rentrer sous des arcs de
triomphe
vous serez acclamé comme des vainqueurs
si napoléon motive autant ses soldats
c'est qu'il va leur demander d'accomplir
des miracles et d'accepter beaucoup de
sacrifices
car pour battre un an et demi supérieur
en nombre et mieux équipés il a décidé
de transgresser toutes les règles de la
guerre avec napoléon de l'art de la
guerre il en est plus question
ce qu'on a connue autrefois avec le xiv
et louis cainne apollon explose
finalement les schémas traditionnels
bonaparte lui il applique des techniques
nouvelles la technique c'est le choc
il faut un choc le plus vite possible il
faut une bataille attaques sur les
flancs à revers mon cirque le mans ou
coup de bluff
pendant 18 jours napoléon mène ses
hommes dans des attaques ultra rapide
qui créé la surprise chez l'adversaire
ils les contourne et les bas sur un
point précis les disperse et s'occupe de
l'année suivante et s'occupe de l'armée
suivantes ainsi de suite c'est très
simple mais personne n'y avait pensé
avant lui
[Musique]
napoléon jeu une victoire spectaculaire
c'est la blitzkrieg avant l'heure pour
les armées sardet l'armée autrichienne
c'est quelque chose à laquelle il ne
s'attendait absolument pas en quelques
semaines
tout ça est pulvérisé le 10 mai 1796 les
français à 1 contre 2 enfonce les
autrichiens sur le pont de l'audi un
assaut furieux sauvage qui coûte 1000
morts aux soldats français napoléon
tient enfin sa victoire de prestige et
deux jours plus tard il fait son entrée
dans milan la capitale du nord de
l'italie
il a 26 ans c'est une entrée triomphale
c'est presque une entrée de d'empereurs
romains
d'autant plus que la population de bilan
est très pro française à ce moment là en
ce dimanche de pentecôte
toute la population de milan est dehors
pour acclamer le phénomène bonaparte
pour la première fois napoléon va
ressentir ce qu'il avait découvert dans
ses lectures à l'école militaire
ce sentiment puissant qu'il vous
soulèvent de terre la gloire
à ce moment là il s'est vu dans
l'histoire il a dit ceci je me sentais
emporté dans les airs et je voyais déjà
le monde
fuir sous moi c'est l'idée d'être d'être
soulevés de terre par cette entrée
triomphale à milan donc cette année un
événement clé dans sa vie c'est presque
un basculement napoléon bonaparte a
désormais la gloire
il veut maintenant le pouvoir prendre le
pouvoir mais comment napoléon à 28 ans
le 17 octobre 1797
c'est un homme politique qu'il fait son
retour à paris ils remettent à paul
barras le chef du gouvernement
le traité de campo forme you qui met fin
à la guerre avec l'autriche
il l'a négocié seul avec les autrichiens
sans consulter paul barras c'est la
liste impressionnante de toutes ses
conquêtes
grâce à lui la république française met
la main sur le duché de savoie le comté
de nice
l'italie du nord mais aussi sur la
belgique et la partie de l'allemagne se
trouvant à gauche du rhin de toute son
histoire le territoire français n'a
jamais été aussi étendue
[Musique]
paul barras est effrayée par la
dimension politique prise par napoléon
son petit protégé est devenue la plus
grande menace pour son pouvoir
alors pour l'éloigner il a une idée
complètement folle l'envoyaient à 5000
kilomètres de la france prendre l'egypte
au sultan de constantinople un piège que
napoléon va transformer en un tremplin
vers le pouvoir
[Musique]
le 1er juillet 1798 à la tête d'un corps
expéditionnaire de 50 mille hommes
napoléon débarque dans le port
d'alexandrie pour conquérir l'egypte sur
la terre des pharaons
à 29 ans napoléon bonaparte va écrire
les plus belles pages de sa légende
[Musique]
en egypte il va acquérir une stature
quasi mythologique parce qu'il remet ses
pas dans ceux d'alexandre le grand
soldat songez que du haut de ces
pyramides quarante siècles vous
contemplent à à la bataille des
pyramides en seulement deux heures
napoléon le conquérant pulvérise les
20000 mamelouks du sultan de
constantinople
nouveaux maîtres de l'egypte il se veut
aussi le civilisateur des peuples du
moyen-orient
il est comme une sorte de roi et de rois
tout puissant de roy orientale mais face
à une population locale très hostile la
mission civilisatrice du général
bonaparte va basculer dans une violence
extrême
et c'est dans cette violence que
napoléon va trouver la force et la
détermination pour s'emparer plus tard
du pouvoir en france
[Musique]
au début de l'année 1799 à la tête d'un
détachement de 13 mille hommes napoléon
bonaparte se lance à la conquête de la
palestine le 7 mars
il prend la ville de jaffa après dix
jours d'intenses combats
tout comme il a fait l'apprentissage de
l'art de régner en egypte il fait à
jaffa l'apprentissage de la violence
absolue à jaffa napoléon ordonne un
massacre de prisonniers pour mater
définitivement les populations qui lui
résiste napoléon donne l'ordre à
berthier d'emmener tout le monde sur la
plage et d'exécuter tous les prisonniers
alors les chiffres varient entre 2 et 4
milles c'est voilà c'est ces voix là
quand il faut marquer les esprits y
compris avec un massacre un plan les
choses par leur nom
il sait le faire aussi
pour économiser les munitions les
prisonniers sont tués à l'armé blanche
le bain de sang dure trois jours
[Musique]
et dans le même temps napoléon se rend à
l'hôpital de jaffa pour soulager cette
fois une soixantaine de soldats français
atteint par la peste bubonique
un jour il inflige la mort le
surlendemain il sauve en touchant les
pestiférés et de ce fait il va acquérir
une sorte de force intérieure qu'on ne
lui connaissait pas avant mais que vous
constatez tous ceux qui le rencontreront
à ceux à son retour d'orient disant que
chez lui il y avait quelque chose
d'implacable qui se sentait quelque
chose de dur qu'il tenait au fait que
désormais on sait de quoi il est capable
c'est à dire d'une violence extrême il
est capable de tout qui a pas de limite
dans ce qu'il peut faire
napoléon c'est maintenant que l'heure de
son retour en france a sonné la nouvelle
qui lui arrive de paris lui font
comprendre que la situation tourne au
désastre pour paul barras la guerre en
europe a repris et les territoires qui
avait conquis napoléon sont perdus les
uns après les autres notamment l'italie
et le comté de nice épuisé par des
années de troubles révolutionnaires et
écoeuré par la corruption de paul barras
le peuple français réclament le retour
de son héros bonaparte et c'est que la
france est face à une situation
difficile
il sent qu'elle est peut-être prêt à
céder il se dit c'est le moment je dois
incarner le sauveur
alors le 23 août 1799 à l'insu de ses
hommes
il embarque sol pour la france à 29 ans
il se sent prêt à renverser cette
canaille comme il l'appelle maintenant
barras et son entourage
il sent que c'est son moment et que rien
ne pourra s'opposer à ça marche
est-ce qu'il est convaincu de son destin
pour moi ils risquent beaucoup une
déserte il abandonne son art mais
c'était uniquement reims où la
révolution napoléon a pris tous les
risques mais il a eu du nez
un mois plus tard il est accueilli en
france comme la providence
[Musique]
au retour d'égypte de napoléon il a été
acclamé de son débarquement jusqu'à son
arrivée à paris on l'acclamé on faisait
des poèmes et c'est ce qui fait que
cette remontée d'egypte
c'est la montée vers le pouvoir si
bonaparte avait des doutes sur la
possibilité de prendre le pouvoir au
retour d'egypte est plus du tout le
problème c'est qu'il n'a pas l'âge
requis pour prendre le pouvoir
légalement en france
peu importe il va s'en emparer par la
force c'est le coup d'état du 18
brumaire
le 9 novembre 1799 napoléon fait
irruption dans la salle du conseil des
cinq sens là où siègent les députés de
la république
ils réclament le pouvoir pour défendre
la patrie qui dit il serait menacé de
très grands dangers
il a aucune notion de ce qu'est la vie
parlementaire et donc il essaye de leur
parler évidemment il va pas pouvoir
prononcer deux mots les députés eurent
le hors la loi hors la loi napoléon est
sur le point de manquer son coup d'état
alors il sort haranguer les soldats qui
l'attend dehors et il demande à son bras
droit murat de faire évacuer la salle
par la force
hélas ce moment là vivent bonaparte et
c'est napoléon a repris ses esprits et
c'est donc il demande au général murat
de faire évacuer la salle est alors
murat à ce moment là un mot qui aurait
pu être historique il entre dans la
salle ils crient au député citoyens vous
êtes dit sous quelle phrase merveilleuse
mais il croit bon d'ajouter foutez moi
tout le monde dehors
évidemment ça gâche tout
ce jour-là napoléon bonaparte l'enfant
d'ajaccio
descendant d'une famille corse d'origine
chinoise prend le pouvoir en france
il n'a que 30 ans n'a plus bonaparte
prenant le pouvoir
c'est comme si
un jeune homme d'origine algérienne avec
tout d'un coup pris le pouvoir en france
à l'occasion d'un coup d'état militaire
bien qu'il soit le militaire le plus
populaire du pays
au fond de lui même napoléon se sont
toujours un étranger un immigré dans
cette france qu'il s'apprête à gouverner
et au fond il ne se sentira jamais
vraiment français il se sentira toujours
dans un rapport d'extériorité mais ça va
être sa force parce que ce sens en
extérieur il va avoir la faculté de très
bien comprendre les français et leur
passion et parce qu'ils ne partagent pas
leur passion il va avoir la faculté de
les réconcilier
et c'est ça qui va être sa force en
prenant le pouvoir
à l'aube du 19e siècle napoléon
bonaparte va écrire quinze années de
l'histoire de france
quinze années parfois flamboyante
parfois tragiques la france feront
naître à jamais transformé
[Musique]